is wonderful wonderful wonderful to be
back in New York I just popped very
quickly to Venice to spit on Chris Pine
but Fred not we're back
for Harry Styles sometimes spit happens
yeah you know what we're talking about
this viral moment with Chris Pine at the
Venice Film Festival which had the
internet wondering did Harry spit on
Chris
[Music]
but just a day later during Harry's tour
stop at Madison Square Garden the singer
left off the claims this is our 10th
show at Madison Square Garden
is wonderful wonderful wonderful to be
back in New York I just popped very
quickly to Venice to spit on Chris Pine
Apple we're back
we gotta watch the original clip again
to fully understand what's going on here
they're all in Venice at the premiere of
their film don't worry darling
[Applause]
Chris in his seat appears to have a
reaction to something as Harry
approaches and takes his seat the
internet went in analyzing every frame
and rumors spread like wildfire that
Harry possibly Spit on His co-star
[Music]
didn't take long for the claim to make
it all the way to the actors and Chris's
rep quickly shut it down telling E.T
it's quote a complete fabrication and
the result of an odd online illusion
that is clearly deceiving and allows for
foolish speculation there is nothing but
respect between these two men and any
suggestion otherwise is a blatant
attempt to create drama that simply does
not exist I can't even tell you and how
about this when filming wrapped in 2020
Chris told ET how much he enjoyed
working with Harry Harry Styles is an
absolute Delight he's the one of the
most professional people I've ever met
couldn't be kinder more gracious I mean
really I was like I was stunned by this
this kitties off the charts cool yep and
now even cool enough to laugh off spit
game I just popped very quickly to
Venice to spit on Chris Pine
and bring everything back to as it was
in this world
[Music]
beautiful